good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
1947 object class
uclid special containment procedures SC
P 1947 is to be contained in a room
shielded with a minimum of 2 cm of lead
scp1 1947 is currently held in room 214b
at site 16 scp1 1947 is not to be
removed from room 214b without the
consent of an 05 level director scp1
1947 is to remain within a 1 M cubed
copper mesh enclosure at all times radio
and microwave receivers are to be placed
within the enclosure and checked for
consistency on a monthly basis any
change in SCP 1947's emissions should be
recorded and reported to Dr Alberts any
further experimentation on scp1 1947 is
strictly
forbidden description SCP 1947 is a
sphere with a diameter of approximately
46 cm two lobes protrude from the sphere
on opposite sides the exposed surface of
scp1 1947 is is mainly composed of an
iron nickel alloy with Trace Amounts of
indium SCP 1947 was found near Zambia on
approximately it was initially
discovered in a small Craner by a local
farmer SCP 1947 was brought to the
attention of the foundation by agent
moan a low-level operative stationed in
Zambia standard testing procedures for
potentially anomalous objects revealed
that SCP 1947 was periodically emitting
microwaves with a frequency of either
1415 or 1425 mahz the emissions were
found to alternate between the two
frequencies in a manner which encoded a
series of images for further details see
technical report
1947a as a SCP 1947 has halted the
emission of microwaves and is now
emitting high power radio waves with
varying frequencies of approximately 6
GHz current emissions are being directed
to an area in
space roughly towards the galactic
center all transmissions by SCP 1947
should be blocked to prevent
unauthorized reception of the signals
the current status of scp1 1947 is
addressed in document
1947b available to personnel with
appropriate
clearance technical report
1947a SCP 1947 was originally classified
as safe and given a low research
priority Junior researcher schz was
assigned to SCP 1947 for a period of 3
years his final report is appended it
was his findings which prompted the
upgrade of SCP 1947 from safe to uid as
well as the updated containment
procedures personnel with level four
clearance or higher are able to access
the supplementary data provided in
document
1947b Dr Al
berts SCP 1947 technical report upon
discovering that scp1 1947 was emitting
microwaves I was tasked with recording
and analyzing its output the emissions
of scp1 1947 encoded a series of images
these are presented below the relevant
technical details are
included SCP 1947 was found to emit
microwaves with a frequency of either
1,4 15 mahz or
1,425 MHz analysis revealed that
microwaves of a given frequency were
emitted by scp1 1947 for a minimum of
1.73 seconds before switching to the
alternate frequency the longest
continuous emission of a given frequency
was
17643 seconds emission occurred in
blocks of
17,640 73 seconds and after each block
cp1 1947 would stop transmitting for
7958 seconds before continuing with the
next block after five blocks were
transmitted a double length pause of
159.5mm mission time of 1.73 seconds
became apparent the frequencies were
emitted for variable times but they were
all multiples of 1.73 seconds it's
seemed clear that an emission of a given
frequency for 1.73 seconds was the
discrete unit of SCP 1947's code at this
point I was sure that the code was
binary in nature one frequency was
analogous to one the other to zero the
Breakthrough came after I realized that
each block of the missions equated to
10,201 *
1.73 the square root of 10,21 is 101 a
prime number I arranged each one and
zero on a 101 by 101 grid and a pattern
became apparent in the set of images
shown below each image is 101X 101
Square each black pixel represents 1.73
seconds of emission at
1,415 MHz and each white pixel
represents 1.73 seconds of emission at
1,425 MHz these images represent the
totality of data transmitted byp 1947's
binary code image one this seems to be a
reference image each bar has a length
corresponding to a prime number between
2 and
97 image two the top of the image
appears to be a stylized graphic of a
star system with six planets if that is
correct the brackets around the fourth
planet from the Star could represent a
ringed planet or a planet of particular
importance the lower half of the image
appears to be sort of map relating the
position of the star system to
astronomical
landmarks image three this image appears
to be a stylized representation of a
bipedal creature the circular object to
the right of the image has a strong
resemblance to scp1
1947 if the image is to scale the
bipedal creature would be approximately
3 m
tall image four unknown speculations
include a stellar field map genetic
information of the the creature shown in
image 3 or yet another
code image 5 this image was discovered
to be a representation of energy levels
in a hydrogen atom an electron
transitioning from the second lowest to
the lowest energy level in a hydrogen
atom releases a photon with a wavelength
of 122 nanom this is shown in the top
left of the image the bottom of the
image was determined to display photons
with a wavelength of 244 nanom directed
against SCP
1947 after the meaning of the fifth
image was discovered we tried exposing
SCP 1947 to a UV laser with a wavelength
of 244 nanom we had hoped that this
would reveal more information about the
nature of SCP
1947 however SCP 1947 stopped
transmitting microwaves after we exposed
it to the UV laser we then found it had
switched to emitting radio waves at a
frequency of around 6 GHz the radio wave
being emitted Now by SC scp1 1947 are
frequency modulated in a complex way the
current signal is beyond our
capabilities to decipher Additionally
the signal is highly directional and
highly powerful SCP 1947 is sending a
signal into space and data redacted By
Request of 05 command Junior researcher
shirs the following information is
classified access is available to all
level four person L and above on a need
to know
basis document
1947b SCP 1947 status as of 2707
2010 this document assumes at least a
cursory familiarity with the technical
report prepared by Junior researcher
shirtz on
23228 I authorized the use of a UV laser
on SCP
1947 we initially thought thought that
SCP 1947 had been deactivated by
exposure to the laser however 3 weeks
later we discovered the new radio
emissions they encor a highly complex
signal which we studied for almost a
year without making any progress on the
decoding all we managed to discover was
that scb1 1947 continuously broadcast a
signal with repeating and nonre
repeating elements eventually we
realized that the radio waves being
transmitted by a c in 1947 were directed
towards the constellation Scorpius this
directionality was maintained regardless
of the orientation of scp1
1947 it is now apparent that SCP 1947
was broadcasting information towards
Scorpius for a period of approximately 1
year the signal sent by SCP 1947 during
that time period will undoubtedly reach
their intended destination at some point
in the future as of 18 1 2009 SCP 1947
is contained within a
electromagnetically shielded Ru this
should prevent any additional
transmission of
information curiously the central
location in the star map provided in the
second image from scp1 1947 C technical
report does not appear to correspond to
any star in the vicinity of scorpus the
lines shown are not correlated with the
known positions of stars pulsars nebula
or other potential astronomical
landmarks additionally no Stone near
scorpus is known to possess six planets
in the configuration shown by the first
image of scp1
1947 since scp1 1947 was found there
have been four additional known
discoveries of very similar objects one
in the US two in Russia and one in
Thailand these additional scp1 1947 like
objects designated scp1 1947 L were
recently determined to transmit similar
sets of images by the same method as SCP
1947 although each object appears to
present a different version of images 2
and four the four different iterations
of image 2 decoded so far are roughly
similar except for the presentation of a
different configuration of the star
system at the top of the image as well
as a superficially similar star map with
the lines in alternate positions one of
those additional star Maps appear to
correspond to locations near
Scorpio also each object analyzed
encodes a version of image 4 with a
different pattern at the Central Square
the meaning of image 4 is still unclear
at least one scp1 1947 l encodes a sixth
image of a seemingly random pattern of
dots similar to those in image 4 three
Su 1947 L's are currently stored in an
electromagnetically shielded deep
storage locker at site 21 those have not
been activated by exposure to a UV laser
at least one SCP 1947 L is not currently
held by the foundation and acquisition
of the missing scp1 1947 L is a high
priority goal the fact that at least
five objects similar to rcp1
1947 including rcp1 1947 itself unnown
to exist is a worrying Prospect
considering the likely extraterrestrial
Arin of SCP 1947
this raises the possibility that a large
number of scp1 1947 L's may be scattered
around the Galaxy to serve an unknown
end Dr
Alberts this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran jack wall o crap guy James
sabba Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazan worthy fire cubster Dean
Dingus Mr
duchu oscuro Vision Grim near extra
moments
123 and Swift
raw if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
you